a test is an order  five enhanced clones more capable than  an army  yet they exhibit a concerning level of  disobedience  in this regard for orders  what else you got give me more  our squad's nothing but trouble  [Music]  but we get the job done  you're climb force 99 you know who we  are  hunter let's go  echo hyper drives online tick prepping  to jump  reckon let's blow something  [Music]  i want clone force 99 found and wiped  out  the galaxy's a dangerous place to be  we need to get out of here  [Music]  what do you say kid you want to come  with us how can i help  the clone wars have ended  you can either adapt and survive  or die with the past  the decision is yours  we do what we do  strapping kit  you